Es… difícil, es imposible…. NO, no creo
que podamos hablar del Mar Caribe sin hablar
de la República Dominicana.
Principal destino turístico, la economía
de mayor tamaño e incluso la montaña más
alta de todo el Caribe.
Amigos, desde que pusimos en marcha este canal,
uno de los vídeos que con más insistencia
nos habéis pedido es, precisamente, uno sobre
la República Dominicana
Pues bien, hemos tardado un poquito…. pero
finalmente ya está aquí. Amigos, en este
vídeo nos vamos al Caribe.
La República Dominicana es un lugar muy especial
de América Latina. Y no lo digo solo porque
aquí podamos encontrar rincones tan increíbles
como Punta Cana, Bayahibe o Puerto Plata entre
otros muchos.
Sino también porque esta fue primera tierra
que tocó Cristóbal Colón cuando descubrió
América en 1492. [Sí, así es. Para bien
o para mal, aquí comenzó, aquí se puso
en marcha lo que hoy conocemos como América
Latina]
Su capital, Santo Domingo fue la primera ciudad
de todo el continente americano. Aquí se
construyó la primera catedral, la primera
universidad y el primer hospital.
Pero… sí, es verdad, si por algo asociamos
hoy a la República Dominicana es, precisamente,
por el turismo.
(LA REVOLUCIÓN DEL SOL)
Esta es con mucha diferencia la mejor cara
de este país. Y no es para menos.
Amigos, la República Dominicana está de
moda.
Gracias a sus 1.600km de costa, a los más
de 400 km de impresionantes playas caribeñas,
a a sus campos de golf y a sus enormes resorts,
el país está viviendo un impresionante boom
turístico.
Claro que… la historia viene de lejos.
Fijaos, ya durante la década de los 40, el
por aquel entonces dictador plenipotenciario
de la isla, el General Rafael Leónidas Trujillo,
dio la orden de que se fomentará el turismo
[Probablemente, con la intención de llenarse
aún más el bolsillo].
De esta forma en 1944 se inauguró el Malecón
de Santo Domingo y se abrió el primer hotel
de lujo de la ciudad, el Hotel Jaragua.
Años más tarde, en 1968, se aprobó la primera
legislación que consideraba de interés nacional
el desarrollo turístico. Así que como veis,
las cosas vienen de atrás.
(Ahora bien, en los últimos años el despegue
ha sido total. En 2017, la República Dominicana,
un país con poco más de 10 millones de habitantes,
logró atraer a más de 7 millones de turistas.
El crecimiento está siendo tan rápido que
se espera que en no más de 3 años el país
logrará superar la barrera de los 10 millones
de turistas internacionales.)
Y desde luego, tal y como os podéis imaginar
todo esto tiene consecuencias:
En tan solo los últimos 5 años la inversión
extranjera directa ha crecido más de un 500%,
es decir se ha multiplicado por 6.
La República Dominicana tiene hoy más de
80.000 habitaciones de hotel… y la cifra
no deja de crecer.
("Para que se hagan una idea, para acomodar
a todos estos visitantes, en 2017 los hoteles
dominicanos ya abrieron 8,366 nuevas habitaciones
y están en construcción unas 15,000 adicionales”.
Danilo Medina, Presidente de la República
Dominicana.)
¿El resultado? El turismo es ya la principal
actividad económica de la isla, y si tenemos
en cuenta tanto la riqueza que genera directa
e indirectamente… supone 1 de cada 4 pesos
que genera la economía ¡El 25%!
[Podemos decir que la República Dominicana
ha descubierto y está empezando a explotar
su particular petróleo]
Y, amigos,en esta línea casi todas las noticias
son buenas. Fijaos en uno de los últimos
logros cosechados… a cambio de romper con
Taiwan.
(“El Gobierno de China Popular se abre al
turismo dominicano
Las autoridades chinas declaran a República
Dominicana como destino turístico para sus
ciudadanos” El Día.)
Claro que… esperad un momento… porque
aquí no termina todo. Amigos, la República
Dominicana también tiene otra cara.
Y es que aquí, en este país, podemos encontrar
muchas de las luces, sí,… pero también
muchas de las sombras que hoy encontramos
en Latinoamérica. Atentos.
(LA OTRA CARA)
La república dominicana ha conseguido tener
una de las tasas de crecimiento más altas
de América Latina y el Caribe en los últimos
25 años.
Precisamente este buen desempeño ha logrado
que en paridad de poder adquisitivo, el país
tenga unas de las 10 rentas per cápita más
altas de toda Latinoamérica.
Con casi 17.000 dólares, la República Dominicana
está mano a mano con Costa Rica y muy por
encima de países como Perú, Colombia o Ecuador.
(Sin embargo, esa no es toda la historia.
A pesar de todo el 32% de los dominicanos,
una de cada tres personas vive por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza; la esperanza media
de vida apenas supera los 70 años y la tasa
de mortalidad infantil es casi 5 veces más
alta que en los países desarrollados.)
Tal vez esta es la razón que explique que
tan solo en los Estados Unidos podamos encontrar
a millón y medio de dominicanos… y que
tras el turismo las remesas sean la segunda
mayor fuente de riqueza.
Pero… dicho esto, creo que la pregunta que
todos nos podemos hacer es, ¿Por qué, Cómo
es posible que semejante paraíso no haya
conseguido despegar del todo?
Pues amigos… la respuesta está en que en
esta tierra caribeña vamos a encontrar algunos
de los “males” que desgraciadamente están
extendidos en muchos países de América Latina.
[Sí,en 1492 aquí comenzó la historia moderna
de la región. Ahora, 526 años más tarde,
encontramos en este mismo sitio un buen reflejo
de lo mejor y lo peor de América Latina.]
Pero... entrando ya en materia, la primera
gran sombra que podemos encontrar es el empecinamiento
que parece existir en esta región por las
políticas que ya han demostrado una y otra
vez que no funcionan.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en toda la región el
trabajo informal, el empleo irregular, es
un problema…
(Por un lado, los trabajadores que están
expuestos a esta situación, a la informalidad,
tienen salarios más bajos , condiciones más
precarias, mayor inestabilidad y también
problemas para obtener financiación, ya sea
para comprarse una casa, para invertir en
un negocio o para formar bien a sus hijos.
Y… es que... claro, al fin y al cabo una
empresa va a invertir mucho menos dinero en
un empleado si está contratado de forma irregular.
Por otro lado, para el gobierno también es
un problema, por ejemplo, a la hora de cobrar
impuestos.)
Pues bien, en la República Dominicana el
empleo informal afecta a 6 de cada 10 trabajadores.
Pero es que además en este país la cifra
no solo no se reduce sino que está creciendo.
En 2017, por ejemplo, los únicos puestos
de trabajo formales que se crearon fueron
en el sector público.
¿Y que nos están diciendo estos datos? Pues
que existen muchas barreras y cargas a la
contratación formal: burocracia, impuestos,
regulaciones desfasadas, que alguien que monta
un negocio tenga que pagar impuestos incluso
antes de ganar un solo dólar, etc, etc…
Y todo eso, lógico, dificulta que la economía
privada cree empleos de calidad….
Así que con los datos en la mano… creo
que lo normal sería decir… oye pues…
tendremos que impulsar la contratación formal
cambiando lo que no funciona ¿Verdad? Pues
no, nada de eso, no hay manera.
Lo mismo pasa con la política comercial.
Veréis en un país con un mercado local pequeño,
como es el caso, precisamente, de la República
Dominicana el sector exterior es fundamental.
Obvio ¿No?
Pues bien, en este país encontramos por así
decirlo dos situaciones diferentes.
(Por un lado, Las zonas francas, donde las
empresas que se instalan, tienen condiciones
favorables, tanto regulatorias como fiscales
a cambio de que básicamente solo se dediquen
a la exportación, cumplan algunos criterios
y sean aprobadas por el gobierno.
Por otro lado, están las empresas normales…
que son, por supuesto, la inmensa mayoría.
Pues bien, más de la mitad de todas las exportaciones
tienen su origen en las zonas francas…
Y, además, en los últimos años las exportaciones
desde estos lugares vienen creciendo de media
más de un 5% cada año.)
En cambio, las exportaciones de las empresas
dominicanas comunes…. bueno… echad un
vistazo a este gráfico.
Entonces viendo esto… la pregunta que yo
me hago es… si las zonas francas funcionan….
¿Por qué no extender sus beneficios al resto
del país para que así las empresas dominicanas
sean más competitivas? Pues no, tampoca nada
de eso.
Y luego… también está el tema del déficit,
el gasto público y la deuda…. que a pesar
de la gran cantidad de malas experiencias
sigue siendo un vicio de muchos gobernantes
de latinoamérica [Y, ojo, también de España]
Aquí, la República Dominicana tampoco se
salva. Desde 1990 el gasto público de la
República Dominicana se ha multiplicado…
atentos… por 18. Aquí el déficit público
es casi una tradición.
Ahora bien, un momento…. Puede que estéis
pensando… Enrique… estamos hablando de
un país que está saliendo de la pobreza…
hay muchas cosas que hacer… hay que crear
infraestructuras…. puertos, aeropuertos,
carreteras, etc, etc… para que el país
crezca.
Pues… ¿Sabeis cual es el tipo de gasto
que más crece? No es la inversión pública
sino ¡El gasto corriente! Qué se ha multiplicado
por casi 30 desde 1990.
Y claro… el gasto hay que pagarlo… una
parte con más impuestos que ralentizan la
creación de empleos formales y la inversión,
otra parte se paga con deuda. Fijaos, fijaos
que está pasando con la deuda dominicana…
con la deuda y con los intereses… porque
claro… la deuda tienen intereses. Atentos)
Sí, tal cual. Casi uno de cada cuatro euros
que gasta el gobierno se va a pagar intereses….
es la tercera mayor cifra de toda América
Latina y no para de crecer. ¡Vaya negocio!
(Pues… precisamente, a pesar del despegue
del sector turístico, este empecinamiento,
una y otra vez con políticas que no funcionan,
es lo que explica que los dominicanos tengan
tantos problemas y que aún haya tanta pobreza
en el país.
Fijaos en cómo clasifica este país en el
Índice de Competitividad Global.)
Pero… ¿Qué pasa con los políticos? ¿Será
que están a otras cosas? Atentos.
(LA SOSPECHA)
Amigos, la República Dominicana es un país
fantástico y tiene un futuro prometedor…
Y la verdad cuando logre el gran salto…
va a ser casi el paraiso… [Pensadlo un momento:
Buen tiempo, buenas playas y dinero ¿Quién
se va a resistir?]
Pero...hoy por hoy  la República Dominicana
tiene otros dos problemas muy
importantes que puedan frenar el despegue
del país: el primero de ellos es la corrupción.
(“República Dominicana, entre los 50 países
más corruptos, según Transparencia Internacional”
DiarioLibre)
Tal cual como lo escucháis… la República
Dominicana es considerado uno de los países
más corruptos del mundo. Según el ranking
de Transparencia Internacional tan solo Venezuela,
Haití, Guatemala y Nicaragua están en peor
situación en Latinoamérica.
Aquí la corrupción a todos los niveles es
muy habitual… Las sospechan van desde el
actual presidente socialista, Danilo Medina,
al que se le acusa de haber financiado su
campaña electoral con coimas y sobornos hasta
la propia policía.
(De hecho, en la República Dominicana, fue
donde la empresa Odebrecht instaló su centro
de coordinación de los sobornos que pagaba
a nivel internacional a cambio de contratos.
Y por supuesto… muchos de estos sobornos
se quedaron aquí, casi 100 millones de dólares.
que se sepa, fueron recibidos por políticos
y funcionarios a cambio de concesiones, adjudicaciones
de obras y contratos públicos.)
Pero desgraciadamente aquí no termina todo,
el otro problema… que está creciendo es
el narcotráfico.
La República Dominicana es considerada por
los Estados Unidos como uno de los países
puente, uno de los centros de distribución
de narcóticos más importantes.
(“A los narcotraficantes no les resulta
fácil exportar drogas desde Venezuela. Allí
hay pocos vuelos comerciales, escaso tráfico
marítimo, el sector pesquero ha colapsado
y no hay turismo. Pero República Dominicana,
a 1.400 kilómetros de distancia, tiene todo
esto”. InSight Crime)
De hecho, según la DEA y los servicios de
inteligencia europeos, hoy por hoy la República
Dominicana es uno de los principales países
de tránsito para los narcóticos que se dirigen
a Estados Unidos y el más frecuente para
los cargamentos de coca que se dirigen a Europa.
Y evidentemente esto supone un riesgo importante…
pero de esto hablaremos en otro vídeo.
En cualquier caso amigos, que quede claro.
Estos son problemas, desgraciadamente comunes
a casi toda la región.
La República Dominicana ha conseguido mucho
en las últimas décadas, es un lugar fantástico
y su futuro es prometedor. En este vídeo
os hemos querido mostrar algunas de las causas
que explican que las cosas en este país no
vayan tan bien como deberían.
[Por cierto, uno de los amigos a los que más
aprecio tengo es precisamente de la República
Dominicana… así que doy fe de que además
aquí hay gente estupenda]
En fin… si te ha resultado interesante este
vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
al canal para estar al tanto de todas nuestras
actualizaciones.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.